hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that today features a
Regal Rumble of royalty in the world of
acting that term world may not actually
be big enough for our two featured
thespians today because at least one of
them owns property in a galaxy far far
away and the other one may well have
created the entire known universe I mean
we got God and Darth Vader that's a
pretty good matchup who wins I'll
refrain from answering that existential
query and instead introduce you to
today's guest Morgan Freeman and James
Earl Jones I'm your host Mark Ellis and
you think my voice is pretty commanding
wait until you hear from those two don't
make me destroy you I've been expecting
you as usual here on verses neither star
will be appearing here in person could
they uh could they send up a voicemail I
listen to that we all would I've been
waiting for decades technically this
program is a competition but it's really
just an excuse to honor two of the
all-time heavyweights in terms of cinema
theater Penguin activity narrating and
news program introductions this is CNN
it isn't always the case the two pop
culture cons are also a couple of the
most respected performers in the history
of you know performing they've been
relevant for seemingly as long as
Dionysus and now we get to honor their
esteemed resumes by making them fight
look out Morgan James has a wicked right
hook after portraying real-life boxing
Legend Jack Johnson but then Jones has
to beware of Freeman too he may have
wanted that quiet retired life and
Unforgiven but if Clint Eastwood shows
up needing a favor you know what they're
both great my life wouldn't be the same
without either of y'all and does my
voice sound higher than normal today
maybe just in comparison to Morgan and
James if there's a round table in
Hollywood these two incredible actors
are definitely Knights seated at it
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two Tomato
Meter slash audience score round three
iconic rolls round four penguin suits
and then we'll do a Wild Card round it
could involve anything from Sports
movies to biopics the who's Kevin
Costner film is better Robin Hood prince
the thieves taking on Field of Dreams
well kev's accent plays better in the
baseball movie but in Robin Hood we get
Morgan Freeman vaulting over a wall
courtesy of a catapult launched by
Christian Slater F me he did clear it
and both these Legends have cleared
every bar there is to Vault over in
Hollywood movies stage screen Earth
Mustafar they've conquered it all and
their films even ones made decades ago
still seem to be prominently featured in
today's rotation of beloved films and
performances I was trying to get deeper
in my register there but you know what
I'll leave the command of narration to
the pros while I radio DJ my way through
five intense rounded versus and caller
12 is going to win those Spin Doctors
tickets Two Princes of performance are
about to Duke it out here and you can
get involved comment with your favorite
Morgan Freeman roll the best of James
Earl Jones's catalog have at it below if
the like button is there I guess you
click it my voice is going too high I'll
figure it out but for now it's time to
get it on thank you good luck round one
box office for decades and seemingly
centuries folks have been lining up
around the block busting into theaters
to witness the greatness of Morgan
Freeman and James Earl Jones on the big
screen even if some audiences weren't
aware that they would be blessed with a
performance from either goat these guys
are awesome whether appearing in
physical form or if it's just their
vocal cords cashing the paycheck either
way those efforts will Factor
prominently into this round that's all
about putting butts in seats Star Wars
was pretty good at that Not only was A
New Hope a cultural phenomenon when it
was released in the summer of 1977 so
much of that business was repeat
customers flocking back for more Darth
Vader badassery David prows his imposing
Visage inside a shiny black costume was
scary enough but then that machine more
than man talked chills dripped down the
spine of every Rebel scum and moviegoers
to this very day don't act so surprised
Star Wars tractor beamed in 775 million
dollars worldwide in 1977 money making
it the highest grossing film ever at the
time yet now in the year what year is it
2023 already God that calendar flies
Here and Now That Hall is just good
enough to be Jimmy's I shouldn't call
him that my bad apology accepted his
fifth best effort his top four include
two lion kings and two other Star Wars
movies the live action I guess 2019 lion
effort is King here with a 1.6 billion
dollar Feast then we have the rise of
Skywalker which has a few vaderie notes
and Rogue one which has some wonderful
Darth punery both leaping over the
billion dollar hurdle and then the 1995
OG Lion King which roared to 986 million
dollars The Empire Strikes Back and
return to the Jedi team up to make
another billion bucks for Jones but it
wasn't done sitting on a throne just yet
Coming to America in which he plays the
king of Zamunda got to 288 million
dollars he does well as an admiral too
in Tom Clancy smashes like The Hunt for
Red October Patriot Games and clear and
present danger that trail would combine
for almost 600 million dollars in U.S
coin oh and he's a judge in summersby
remember that movie Jody Foster is
Richard Gere her hubby or not I mean I
don't know a ton of ladies that would
complain about Richard Gere showing up
it's a big movie for the 1990s and it
earned 140 million bucks very well okay
so Morgan Freeman has quite a task ahead
of him James Earl Jones had the benefit
of performing in huge space fantasies
epic Disney Adventures and international
Espionage bangers can Freeman keep up
well if he's got that Batmobile tumbler
thing probably he's techwiz lucious Fox
an all-time great name and Christopher
Nolan's Batman Trilogy those movies
perform well I'm told Batman began with
a nice 358 million dollar jog not bad
then Joker showed up the Dark Knight
maniacally laughed all the way to the
bank with a one billion dollar deposit
then filled the other Vault with another
bill courtesy of The Dark Knight Rises
James Earl Jones Is Awesome as a king
Freeman is pretty darn believable as God
is this heaven
oh this is Mount Everest
you should flip on the Discovery Channel
from time to time Bruce Almighty earned
almost 500 million dollars Evan Almighty
tacked on another 174 million bucks and
as the president of these United States
He fares well Too Deep Impact rocketed
to 349 million dollars and then the
Gerard Butler Fallen franchise where
Freeman I think eventually assumes the
role of commander-in-chief if I'm not
mistaken minted over 500 million dollars
in that three film stretch oh and Morgan
also does some ADR that's what we in the
good throat Biz call voice over and any
human or penguin will tell you that his
Gravely rasp adds gravitas to any
situation the penguin War of the Worlds
sucked up over 600 million dollars The
Lego Movie built a 468 million dollar
total and wobbling to 133 million
dollars in 2005 was La Marsh de lamper
also known as March of the Penguins did
you all know I spoke fluent French well
the answer is we Madam you should say
aim I spent a few hours at Charles de
galle airport one time first class
Lounge one of the best showers ever had
was I supposed to be there I don't think
so Okay so we've established that in
front of the camera or behind a
microphone Morgan and James Drive big
business to the local Multiplex but who
Reigns Supreme as king or president or
God itself Jones has accrued 8.8 billion
dollars of the box office over a
legendary career but Freeman has amassed
11 billion dollars James does have the
higher per movie average at 196 million
dollars per picture to Morgan's 149
million bucks but I lean on me towards
Morgan Freeman here for no other reason
than he's appeared in a few more big
time movies and Jones was seriously in
Rise of Skywalker for like a line I have
been every voice you have ever heard
inside your head it was a good line to
be sure and that movie's great you hear
me internet it's awesome wonderful
clothes are the greatest Saga of all
time but Morgan Freeman gets the win in
round one and goes up one to nothing I
find your lack of faith
round two Tomato Meter slash audience
score God has the lead and that ain't
gonna make Darth Vader happy one bit but
when you think about it does anything
make Vader happy like the guy never
Smiles you got your death you got
destruction protesting sand I don't like
sand I guess he does enjoy flying his
custom GT Shelby TIE fighter but will
that Aid in a bet him in round two which
is all about how the critics and
audiences felt about your movie after
the bag of popcorn had been munched yeah
the galactic operas tend to do well
according to George Lucas and Disney's
wallet and the Tomato Meter the best
Star Wars movie of them all in an
unofficial poll I just took in the men's
room 30 minutes ago is return to the
Jedi at a rock solid 83 percent on the
Tomato Meter A New Hope is at 93 and The
Empire Strikes Back tops here with 94
but Jones's best role in the veggie
patch was as lieutenant lotharzog in Dr
Strangelove which is 98 you don't have
to love the bomb but we can all stop
worrying about whether king joffy would
be competitive in this round by the way
coming to America is at 73 the sequels
rotten at 49 why it's fun Wesley Snipes
shows up but we find fresh fare again
with flicks like Field of Dreams at 88
percent Cry the Beloved Country at 85
percent and the animated as in drawn on
paper with maybe a little bit of a PC
helping the 1994 Lion King is at 93 it's
a good start for Jones now for the
counter by Morgan Freeman he was in
Transcendence ooh and Chain Reaction uh
you know what let's start at the top
please he narrated three movies that are
a hundred percent fresh in the Tomato
Meter highlighted by the sequel to La
Marsh de la Emperor they're so cute
we're in their little Tuxedos and his
vocal talents in the Lego talkie helped
construct a 96 tying it with Unforgiven
which is a very different movie but no
less well awesome Gone Baby Gone is 95
of the Tomato Meter glory is 94 and the
Shawshank Redemption is 91 on the TM and
150 according to every college student
and Ted Turner's Bevy of networks I dare
you to turn that movie off if you
stumble upon it on the boob tube that's
what we used to call television get your
minds out of the gutter stop wasting my
time of his Batman efforts Lucius
notched 94 with a dark knight 87 with
the Dark Knight Rises and 84 percent
with Batman Begins what how is the last
one better than arguably the best origin
story in comic book film history if only
there is a podcast where talented minds
and syrupy voices could argue about
whether or not Rotten Tomatoes is wrong
other fresh highlights for Freeman
include Driving Miss Daisy at 84 7 at 82
percent and Invictus where he plays
Nelson Mandela at 76 percent I know what
you're asking where's Robin Hood prince
of Thieves that way well it better be
fresh it's one of the best movies of the
1990s 50 are you kidding me luckily
there's a podcast called oh I already
plugged that damn it but this is why we
also have the verified audience score
I'm sure on this metric the Injustice
committed by the Sheriff of Nottingham
will be rectified and it's 72 percent
here that's just fresh but not enough
come on Morgan Freeman catapult
Christian Slater enough said Shawshank
is even higher rated with the normies
tunneling out his 90 eight percent
followed by sevens ninety five percent
The Dark Knight in Batman Begins are
tied at 94 yeah the audience knows what
they're talking about and a trio movies
at 93 including Unforgiven gory and
Angel has fallen what I know I like the
audience score now I love you return to
the Jedi Return of the King Angel has
fallen great Trilogy closers the mariana
rivera of their respective franchises I
don't have any idea what that means all
right let's all welcome to the play
James Earl Jones now the concept of the
release pitcher wasn't in Vogue back in
the olden days when she was Joe Jackson
was playing ball fair and square but
Field of Dreams is still throwing heat
within 86 percent in the audience aisle
the sand lot speaking of baseball movies
B sits way to 89 and The Lion King from
the 90s is in the 90s at 93 percent
Return of the Jedi is 94 here you see
the audience gets it tying it with dark
Strange Love and rebound the legend of
the goat as in the Earl manigault story
he was a real streetballer whose Feats
on the blacktop have been etched in
mythology for all times one time he took
a 20 bill off the top of a backboard
your move John Morant I don't know what
you're talking A New Hope Grizzles its
way to a 96 percent and Empire tops the
Star Wars Galaxy once again with an
audience approved 97 fresh I love these
dudes so much it pains me to highlight
some of their low lights so we're gonna
go quick and rip the Band-Aid off
apparently jej was in a sequel to Casper
which died on the table at zero percent
on the Tomato Meter silence Three
Fugitives is at 14 and the Meteor Man is
at 25 I like that one comedy Legend
Robert Townsend right it climbs to 36 on
the audience score so you know what
maybe I got that one wrong Morgan
Freeman's dubs include Transcendence
which I cannot stress enough is just not
good 19 chain reaction is good according
to me Keanu Reeves and Rachel Vice but
the lab results have it at a mere 18 run
the test again and the contract with
Morgan Freeman and John Cusack is as low
as Fidelity can get zero percent may God
have mercy on your soul luckily Freeman
plays a pretty good deity so you might
have an in all told James are Jones is
looking again on the board with an
overall Tomato Meter average of a fresh
adjacent 57 percent which tops Morgan
Freeman's 53 percent Freeman mounts
worthy comeback with the audience who
did correctly acknowledge Robin Hood's
freshness with a 59 average that's
practically fresh but Jones is fresh
here 62 average with the audience score
and thus James Earl Jones has his first
win of the day takes round two and ties
the score one to one good busy living or
get busy dying round three iconic rolls
all right we got us a tight ball game
here it's probably going to go down to
the wire and it's at this juncture that
I should point out this round is all
about the most iconic roles these
gentlemen have ever played and have you
seen their resumes I can't and will not
get to every great performance they've
turned in over the years otherwise this
vid would be nine days long and I have a
date this weekend it's a play date with
my dog and another puppy but still filed
under the category of date find me on
the apps speaking of appetizers let's
open this Feast with the roles you know
and love the most Morgan Freeman as the
president in Angel Has Fallen
no look he's in all three of those so
far I hear there's a fourth one on the
way and I do mention it without irony
simply because his presence in action
flicks like these add weight and
dimension and Prestige to the
proceedings would Unforgiven be as
legendary a western without Ned Logan
being the best BFF of all time imagine
Shawshank without red and his ability to
acquire certain goods from time to time
as scrap iron and Million Dollar Baby
and Hoke Colburn and Driving Miss Daisy
you feel the experience of a life well
lived But Not Without Tragedy and
heartbreak in every sequence and I'll
guarantee you that I wouldn't be nearly
as high on Robin Hood p-o-t that's
prince of Thieves for short without
Azeem the great one let's face it
leading Robin of Loxley in his journey
towards becoming an actual adult
Christian Slater is in there too did I
mention that and Slater and Morgan would
be reunited in hard rain a film that
features some of the toughest droplets
ever put to screen come on and guys the
clock is ticking sometimes Freeman can
show up and be the pleasant Elder Father
Figure like in Dolphin Tale or Las Vegas
other times he can get hard-boiled I can
lean on me the sum of all fears or red
then we arrive at possibly his best work
effort 1989's Glory anyone who might
have needed a second to think of who
Morgan Freeman was back then would never
forget after witnessing Sergeant Major
John Rollins it's a stirring portrayal
of conflict on both the battlefield and
inside One's Own Heart James Earl Jones
has a similar way of lending presents to
any film he's attached to that can
include being a shirtless warrior in
Conan the Barbarian for which he and
Arnold Schwarzenegger both won Oscars
I'm now being told that didn't happen
but hey if you can inhabit a role named
Tulsa doom and hold your own next to a
seven-time Mr Olympia you're doing just
fine
yeah
Wendell Pierce is now Jack Ryan's right
hand on the cool Amazon show but Jones
originated on the big screen and it
really doesn't matter if he's on the
front lines making tough decisions with
Jack or relegated to an advisory role
from a hospital bed he still provides an
invaluable Confidant for Tom Clancy's
most famous son he's also been in the
NSA on the Silver Screen anyway thanks
to the fun 90s Tech Thriller sneakers
and let's not forget about Reverend
Stephen kamalo and Cry the Beloved
Country the 1995 film wrestles with
South African apartheid and family
issues and Jones's line delivery is
stunning for example when he retorts
truth but how can he have truth on his
side and not God it's compelling stuff
Morgan plays God occasionally and when
he shows up in the almighties more Bruce
than Evan you believe it it's just that
simple it's a nice companion to his
documentary voiceovers does anyone else
watch the penguin movies and think you
know this guy narrating might have
created those adorable flightless birds
along with everything else Under the Sun
I know I do and we all credit Alfred
with being Bruce Wayne's man hang but
where would Batman be without the genius
of Lucius Fox that's the special project
guy who birthed him his car his suit
whatever that flying thing is as we've
come to expect from a Freeman role he's
a principled man who will only go so far
to Aid bats stopping short of the
tempting technology that would allow him
to spy on literally everyone with a cell
phone even a flip phone even a flip
phone but this round is all about the
most iconic roles of all time and yes
Shawshank would be a much less exciting
place without red the school and lean on
me might not exist and Robin Hood would
be dead he'd just be dead without Morgan
Freeman's health
but James Earl Jones on both sides of
the all-time cinematic father coin if
you flip it and it lands on heads sweet
you get Mufasa a proven leader
benevolent ruler who will do everything
in his considerable power to Aid his
kingdom in this life or the next you are
my son I am your father if the coin
lands on Tails you're getting a very
different Daddy
Darth Vader possibly the greatest
villain this or any other galaxy has
ever seen and the fear he instills
doesn't last without that voice with it
Vader is the be-all end-all when it
comes to power of violence and Obsession
I know the emperor technically ranks
higher on the CIS scale but remember how
that worked out for him
he ain't Catherine anymore neither any
of the rebels unfortunate enough to
participate in borrowing some schematics
that may or may not have contained
information about the Death Star Darth
Vader is a guy you do not want to get on
the wrong side of and it's just one of
the many memorable roles played by James
Earl Jones his Terence man in Field of
Dreams gives a rousing speech about the
importance of baseball in American life
for all earthlings a similar talk could
be delivered about the Vitality of James
Earl Jones's characters to cinema great
efforts by both men here but Jones gets
the win and now takes the lead 2-1 it is
settled round four penguin suit okay you
see this round Titan you think oh Morgan
Freeman's gonna easily win this and he's
going to tie the match as James Earl
Jones ever seen a penguin before well it
doesn't necessarily have to you see
penguins look like they're wearing cute
little dinner jackets kind of like the
tuxedos demanded by the finest award
chosen Hollywood and this phase is all
about how well you're fared when it came
to Tinseltown Super Bowl the Academy
Awards I'd actually be all in favor of
changing the award from an Oscar to a
penguin how cute would that be and the
wobbly bird thing goes to both Morgan
Freeman and James Earl Jones they each
have at least one statue that resembles
a nude C-3PO on their mantle I assume
that's where you put it I haven't been
invited to the residences as of yet I
keep checking that mail though any day
now get yourself in here in the meantime
let's take a walk down memory lane a
road that will detail the careers these
two gems have had as well as the award
show itself and we started in 1970 that
was the year that James Earl Jones
earned his first Oscar nomination for
his lead role as Jack Johnson in the
Great White Hope fun fact about this he
wanted Tony for the same damn role a
couple years earlier suffice to say dude
knew his lines and was cruelly up to the
task but these are two very different
mediums on screen it's all about the
details the close-ups every nook and
cranny of one's face are judged and the
academy decided that his was one of the
five best lead performances of that year
on stage you gotta be able to project to
the back of the room could James Earl
Jones what are we kidding you know who
we're talking about of course he could
he would go on to lose the best actor
now that year to George C Scott who won
for Patton but didn't show up to the
ceremony the whole thing Jones has not
been nominated for an Oscar since which
sounds like an oversight but luckily
they did bestow him with an honorary
Oscar a sort of a Lifetime Achievement
thing at the 2011 ceremony Morgan
Freeman had to wait until 1987 for his
first taste of Oscar finalism when he
was up for best supporting actor for
Street Smart Sean Connery won that year
for The Untouchables then again he got
nominated in 1989 for Driving Miss Daisy
and 1994 for the Shawshank Redemption
the good news is both nominations were
for lead actor the bad news is two guys
named Daniel Day-Lewis and Tom Hanks won
those respective years Shawshank stands
have long had a beef with Forrest Gump
because that flick was more successful
commercially and on the gala circuit I
love both movies imagine that Freeman
would be denied no more once he was up
for best supporting actor with Million
Dollar Baby he took home the gold and
was most recently nominated for best
actor courtesy of Invictus losing out to
another venerable actor who was waiting
to finally earn a goldfella Jeff Bridges
for Crazy Heart a movie that's about a
country singer but could easily be about
stand-up comedy as well trust me so
Morgan has the edge here but James Earl
Jones is sort of an egot that shorthand
for an Emmy Grammy Oscar and Tony they
dang it for not having an Oscar for one
particular performance I will do no such
thing but Morgan Freeman has been a
threat to win an Oscar just about every
year since Street Smart five-time Oscar
nominee not to mention his other award
show wins such as the Cecil B Demille
award which is the Golden Globes version
of a Lifetime Achievement Award the
Golden Globes they know movies and they
know how to reward them just ask the
hilarious comedy the Martian
well Morgan would probably be recognized
on any of the nine planets in this solar
system is it eight now or is it back to
nine what's Pluto status here on Earth
Freeman gets the win in round four and
we're all tied up heading into the final
stage that's goddamn right and now it's
time for the Wild Card round Now You See
Me hey that's another Morgan Freeman
franchise but since he appears in those
films they're not eligible in the round
that's all about now you don't see me as
in the best voiceover artist this is
gonna be impossible really all right
I'll give it a shot Morgan Freeman has
narrated films about purposefully
walking Penguins conveniently titled
March of the Penguins big feather in his
cap but he's also behind the scenes for
America's musical Journey the c word
Born to Be Wild and War of the World he
can also do voiceovers lampooning his
own ability in comedies like The Lego
Movie and remember how James Earl Jones
was in Conan the Barbarian they remade
the movie in 2011 with Jason Momoa no
one really asked for it but it was there
and Freeman narrated it his voice is so
recognizable that actors have been hired
to impersonate him when they can't land
the real koi
I take the bread the whole look you
understand you want money you come to me
remember string of commercials from a
certain very well-known credit card
company that's not Morgan Freeman but
it's sad enough like it and as a result
my credit karma score has plummeted you
forget to eventually you got to pay for
that stuff with real money thanks for
nothing fake Morgan Freeman I saved this
last Freeman mention because it's a nice
segue he narrates Cosmic Voyage which is
wonderful and you might see where I'm
going with this Vader's on that ship
well done Luke very astute and the once
Anakin Skywalker has turned his disdain
for sand into an all-encompassing dark
side-fueled obsession with ruling the
Galaxy the most imposing Baddie ever
could only be voiced by James Earl Jones
and what sways me towards Jones winning
this round is his ability to take that
same tenor to form the compassionate yet
Alpha Mufasa Morgan Freeman can lend his
talents for dramatic or comedic purposes
with equal a plum but Jones can go good
or bad guy or remind you that you're
watching CNN both gents have dabbled in
the religious texts with Freeman hosting
an investigative series on biblical
Scrolls and the like but Jones has a
massively listened to narration of the
King James Bible start to finish can you
imagine that voice reading the book of
Apocalypse that's enough for me to get
James Earl Jones to win in this round
and thus James Earl Jones takes the
match they're both winners today Morgan
Freeman and James Earl Jones together
have narrated Our very lives it seems so
let's give their vocal cords a rest and
turn it over to you dear viewer who's
your all-time favorite between the two
it's kind of odd I picked the guy who
read the Bible as opposed to the dude
who's famous for playing God I really
hope that ruling doesn't come back to
haunt me hit us up at rottentomatoes.com
check out our website all the cool
things we got going everything in the
world of TV movies in between and thank
you for watching versus I'm your host
Mark Ellis and until next time you know
what's going to happen penguin dance
to the side
and the other side
they're cute
[Music]